don't have that background because you
don't have that history and as long as
loyalty is there first and foremost and
that you would treat man and so you
would treat your men
as men don't wrong they have to be men
in the first place and by men i mean
actual masculine men
they have to have the right frame they
have to have the finances in order but
as long as they can see that you have
the right history you have the right
motive and then the loyalty is there
altogether
i think we could all agree in here that
relationship is now going to last and
it's going to be fruitful forever what's
more what's more important a low body
count or loyalty
what's more important
i don't think i need to pick either one
they tend to be the same i'm going to
say they kind of they go hand in hand
because if a girl has a higher body
count it's more baggage it's more excess
he has to deal with it's more like i
hate this term but like alpha widows
yeah it's basically like the x that the
girl can't get over but there's more of
them
the more people she slept with i do
agree with certain points that you said
about game i do agree with body count
and i do
i was raised on
women shouldn't get round through and i
do agree with that and i'll preach that
to my daughters
but i don't what i don't agree with is
the perfect
family the scenario the greatest thing
for a woman is when she's standing in
her living room with 30 people
celebrating her
yeah for some people yeah for some
people that is that is their life goal
i don't think
my my i've got a few people in my family
that can't have kids
so that's the exception that's the
exception and that's an exception so is
to say is to say she can't have kids her
life is any less fulfilled than
my other auntie that has got that maybe
maybe but she's living her best life on
in foreign like is she she's had she's
had to adjust her ultimate you've got me
yeah i hear you so we can adjust and i'm
i don't think her life is any less
fulfilled no it's not it's not going to
be in it no it's not going to be any
less fulfilled i mean technically it
will be
saying she has been through probably
periods of her life but she's wanted to
keep that but but again i mean that is
the exception to the rule and it doesn't
mean she can't be happy but she's not
going to be as happy now that's just the
sad truth of it right but if
if you're a woman i mean to go back to
your previous point
what would a woman want more than to
later on be able to say they're a
grandmother great grandmother with loads
and loads of kids load of people that
have come from there what will i know
you said that that's not every woman's
goal what goal would you say a woman
would value more than that long term
that society hasn't told us you should
have yeah i'm
like i want i want to cut the 30
grandkids 30 great grandkids down to
like eight nine because the cost of
living out here is crazy yeah that's a
lot of christmas presents but the point
is the point is if a woman doesn't
prioritize a family she ends up unhappy
in the long term in general i thought
like
because this is when you survey women
because it's it's all fun and games when
you're still hot right and you still
look good right and you still get
attention from men but at some point
that goes away like no guys are lining
up to date 50 year olds yeah and you're
going to live to be 90. go ahead yeah
sorry and we have that window so that's
why we want that commitment fertility
window yeah yeah so we need to
we need to
optimize in that and try and
find that commitment when we're in that
window
so then so women want women are
nurturing they want to have kids
naturally
not all natural naturally you do
but i believe the only reason why some
women will say they don't and i i
personally believe i'm
yet to be convinced otherwise is because
modern day social conditioning society
has convinced you that's not your
ultimate goal but if you actually
walk into a dark room with nobody in
there by yourself completely quite and
ask yourself what do you want what does
your biology want i think you know the
answer when you ask girls that are 18
and they're graduating high school they
all want to be married with kids that's
the first thing yeah but who sold them
that dream
as well it's definitely not society you
have feminism pushing you can get your
own bag female empowerment like i've
been told from the youngest age that i
can do whatever i want society's telling
you that you should have this big career
yeah and make it on your own and
[ __ ] that's
not what you're doing you're just gonna
if you're gonna be
like a
a high up lawyer with loads of money you
may have loads of money but you'll be
lonely because you won't have
your children you get a couple of more
holidays a year out of your money so
[ __ ] what at the end of the day what
does it matter to you if you've not got
a family that's ultimately what you want
to have children i mean that's the gift
that we have yeah that's not how to
procreate like you're breeding machines
that's literally what you're
biologically designing
i know this but i want to ask you guys
something here
now
the lgbt community yeah should be
allowed to
conduct themselves how they conduct
themselves
right so we
more than likely we're not going to get
any kids from that area yeah yeah
now
the women that we're now telling
go to work go to career and stuff
don't have kids late now we're telling
those women not to have kids what do you
think happens to the human race
when
people stop having kids
they will become distinct when they come
in that's what i'm talking about so we
need a man and a woman to have kids
right mm-hmm
right otherwise we need to continue the
human race and to touch so sort of cut
you in but sorry
but on that point people have got to
understand that what we're fed to
believe we want and what we want on a
dna level cellular level
are two different things and this brings
me back to the very point you all
touched on earlier with regards to what
men are looking for in women and what
women are looking for in men now this is
just for anybody watching at the end of
the day
the simple breakdown
i provide for people is if you're if
you're if you're a man
for any man in this room if i was to sit
here and break down a woman so for
example
i would say she's
she's very very caring she loves her
career yeah
right she's very very driven she's got
loads of friends around her that love
and respect that her family adores the
pieces highly educated
what is every single man in this room
thinking right now
in what sense
if i was to describe a woman and start
off and purely
lay out those
um
attributes or traits or her history
right what what for any guy in here or
any guy listening what question do you
have in mind what's the first question
you have what does she look like thank
you very much right it all comes down to
the aesthetics in the beginning right
now for women
it is slightly different in that
now if i was to say
he's
a great looking guy
chisel jaw
big dick
tall
why
what does he do
thank you very much
you've broke so the first thing you want
to know who is he what does he do what
is connections what's his status right
in society
i think deep down every single woman
asks those questions and if i was to say
along with those things
if i was to drop it on you now say that
he's a complete bum he's going nowhere
in life he still lives in his mum's
basement and he's got no drive to
accomplish anything in life nobody
around him respects him he's got no
friends and there's no girls trying to
hit him up what would you say now
get the [ __ ] away from me is what you're
saying
i always say like we shouldn't say
hypergamy isn't a bad thing like wow
hypergamy is designed for our survival
yeah exactly i don't want to date a bomb
like i i hope to god you guys don't want
to date bombs so you're saying guys
would like a girl who's bummy yes
at least
what a girl a woman being a bum to us we
don't really look at women as bums for
us it's more to do with your loyalty and
it's to do with your attitude in life
whether you're arrogant whether you've
got that
overly confident nature to us it's
repulsive but a woman having no money
and a woman not being well connected do
you think we give a [ __ ] because that's
not our ultimate goal
ultimately on a dna level and this is
what most men need to understand this is
what we act on it's primal so on a dna
level we are ultimately
after good breeding stock so you need to
have and this is this is a woman's
display of good breeding stock good
genes is by having a great physique a
beautiful face she's youthful she's
young she's within that peak fertility
window she does have a clock sooner or
later that that will run out and then
she'll she'll end up on the other side
of that